so the first talk the mornings by Rory
tells gonna tell us about quantified D
randomization okay so hi good morning
everyone thanks for coming I will talk
little give an overview of quantified
randomization this is a broad research
question internalization that was put
forward around four years ago by a
pivotal son I know that goldeye I want
to talk about and survey what we know
and what we understand about this
question at this point so I'm going to
describe some known results and the
underlying techniques and also
limitations of these techniques but
actually my explicit goal and intention
in giving this talk is for you to be
familiar with the question so that you
can see instantiations of it that might
touch will be relevant to things that
you like and that you care about that
you wanna study near the end of the talk
I'm also going to specify several
frontiers that I personally find very
appealing for this problem the last now
please feel free to stop me at any point
and ask questions and as I mentioned
this is a survey talk so it's based on a
sequence of papers among others by gold
I Victor stone viola
Cheng Li cabinets Liu and myself and
works in preparation - Mandarin so our
starting point will be the classical
problem of the randomization circuit
acceptance probability problem in this
standard problem we get as input a
description of a circuit over n bits and
we want to distinguish between the case
that the circuit accepts a strong
majority of its inputs say all-nighter
and the case that C rejects all but a
strong majority of fitting say that all
but the third now it's very easy to
solve using randomness since there is a
large gap we can just sample inputs and
decide but the point is that we want to
do it to terminus tically this is a an
innocent-looking problem but of course
we know that this is essentially pair P
versus VP P in disguise or more formally
this is complete for promise PPP which I
mean to say if we have no restriction on
the circuit class then it's solvable in
polynomial time if and only if promise B
equals promise be
it's hard problem moreover after several
decades of work we know that this
problem is intimately connected to
circuit or bounds so on the one hand
circuit all bounds give the
randomization algorithms either via the
hardness randomness paradigm if we have
strong lower bounds against the Class C
we'll get a PRG for C and week may be
worst case lower bounds can be amplified
strong lower bounds average case and
also typically lower bound proofs
contain techniques that are useful for
our group for randomization algorithms
but on the other hand the animation also
implies the words if the enemy's action
is done via a blackbox manner VIP RG or
hitting set generator then the output
set is a hard function we know that but
a long and clever line of work has shown
that any type of the randomization
implies the role bounds even whitefox
ones so these are indirect arguments and
moreover they're tied down with antelope
islands are tied quantitatively very
closely if we have a faster than the
musician algorithm we get better lower
bounds lower bound against larger
circuits or more explicit functions so
okay since this is a circuit lower
bounds problem unsurprisingly the
unconditional progress hasn't been so
fast so at the moment if the circuit
class is just the class of CNS we still
don't have a strictly polynomial time
algorithm to solve the problem and if we
go up to circuit classes such as this is
zero then for arbitrary polynomial size
then we essentially know nothing if we
knew something it would give lower
bounds which we don't
so round four years ago golden and
Victor stone suggested the following
relaxation of this problem intuitively
instead of distinguishing between
acceptance probability 2/3 and 1/3 let's
try to distinguish between acceptance
probability in 99% and 1% or more
specifically let's fix a parameter B
that quantifies the number of
exceptional inputs this circuit and now
we want to distinguish between the case
that the circuit accepts all but B of
itself and the case that the circuit
rejects all but B of its inputs in the
original problem B was 2 to the N over 3
right 1/3 of diamonds but we want to
relax this problem so we want to handle
B that is much much much smaller good so
now I presented the problem and you
should have at least 2 intuitions and
these intuitions should be conflicting
with each other the first intuition is
like we are all taught in the basic
complexity course the exact constant 1/3
is completely arbitrary it doesn't
matter we can do error reduction and
instead of having B that is 2 to the N
over 3 have been that is much smaller
and the problem will be just as hard as
the original problem they are equivalent
in fact it's 2018 we have very clever
ways for error reduction so we can
expect that the problem even with the
tiny B will be just as difficult as the
original problem but on the other hand
for B equals 0 I know how to solve the
problem if there are no exceptional
inputs also for small biz wicked just go
over 3 times B inputs and take a
majority vote and as you might expect
when we have more clever ways to do it
and just going over 3 times B inputs so
for small B the problem is easy what's
going on so fix a circuit Class C let's
chart the values of P on the left side
we have values of B that are easy B
equals 7 is easy the equals n to the 5
is easy to solve in time maybe n to the
6 and on the right side we have values
that are just as hard as the original
problem maybe 2 to the N over 100 or for
some classes 2 to the N to the point 9
and our first goal will be the most
natural and straightforward thing to do
this is a problem it's natural it's
interesting it's of independent interest
let's see what we can understand
results which values are easy which
values are as hard as the original time
you can learn something just by this but
a more ambitious goal is to use this as
a platform for the randomization in
circuit lower bounds that is we want to
make the red and the green cross we want
to reduce the standard problem to a
setting of B that we can actually solve
by which we can get standard
randomization and lower bounds you can
think of this as in the context of
Ryan's algorithmic method for circuit or
bounds so the method says okay we we do
a non-trivial satisfiability algorithm
and get our bounds or maybe there are no
missing algorithm and get lower bounds
but here this is a further relaxation we
can construct a non-trivial algorithm
for quantified randomization when the
number of exceptional inputs is tiny and
still get lower bounds so in this
context this is a further relaxation of
the algorithmic requirements for circuit
robots let me pause on this for a moment
and say exactly what kind of lower
bounds we can get for quantity from
quantified the randomization so any
blackbox quantified the randomization
that is non-trivial gives lower bounds
in exactly the same way that standard
randomization gives the output set is a
hard function over if we want a white
box to get lower bounds from a white box
algorithm we need to solve it for a
value of B that is red the value of B
that is as difficult as the original
problem to get standard randomization
moreover in contrast to standard the
randomization here we can't trade off
the speed of the algorithm to get lower
bounds against larger circuits this kind
of padding algorithms fail in this
context so it's good and bad it's good
since we can make unconditional progress
right now it's bad because they don't we
don't immediately get any lower bounds
we have to work
I'm going to mention two areas of
research in this context in this talk
the first one will be constant depth
circuits which corresponds to what I
just described the second one near the
end of the talk will be for polynomials
the problem of constructing heating
exaggerators that need to hit only
polynomials that vanish very rarely are
there any questions so far
so constant depth circuits the the title
the headline the thing that you should
remember is that for constant depth
circuits the results that we are able to
obtain in recent years are remarkably
and surprisingly very tight we're going
to both see it and see partial
explanations of how this can be so let's
start with ic0
it's constant that circuits over the
Morgan basis this is a pictorial
description of what's going on and I'm
going to get back to it in one slide so
you don't need to remember the precise
parameter values the point that I want
to show is that your AC zero the red
part and the green part are essentially
touching they're almost touching more
specifically the first theorem is that
for any constant D there is an
unconditional algorithm for quantified
randomization of AC zero of depth D when
the number of exceptional inputs is two
to the N over poly log n where the poly
logarithmic power is essentially the
depth D D minus two this algorithm runs
in very quickly it runs very quickly the
running time is n to the log squared of
n which does not depend on the depth you
should think of this running time is
very quick since if we would have an
algorithm for standard randomization
with this running time we will get the
vast improvement of Hazzard's lower
bounds
so on the other hand we also know the
second theorem for any constant D if we
could do quantify the randomization when
the number of exceptional inputs is
still exponential in n over poly log n
but a logarithmic power instead of D
minus 2 it's now d minus 15 or D minus
20 then we would get standard
randomization of circuits of smaller
depth returning to this picture like 2
to the n to the point 99 we have a poly
time algorithm you can smoothly trade
off the running time for the number of
exceptional inputs up until this point 2
to the n over log n to the D and if we
go a little bit to the right slightly
larger number of inputs 2 to the N over
log n to the D minus 20 then we will get
standard n randomization and lower
bounds for ACC oh yeah for CNF you know
the standard randomization problem can
be solved almost in polynomial time the
result of Gopal are making lying gold
CNF sin a 0 we have quasi-polynomial
time algorithms for standard
randomization and they the lower bounds
that they give match has the lower
bounds if we could may if we could
create algorithms that would have been
faster we would get better
lower bounds and the thing is that when
we do quantify the randomization the
algorithm is extremely quick compared to
those algorithms
okay we're going to see an explanation
of what's going on here in a few minutes
I want to move over to TC zero class of
constant depth circuits with linear
threshold gates so the first theorem is
that there existed the terminus t'k
algorithm running in almost polynomial
time for quantified randomization of
very sparse LTF circuits typically if
the number of wires is slightly super in
here and to the one plus something that
decays exponentially with the death we
can solve the problem when the number of
exceptional inputs is two to the n -
there's something that becomes close to
one with the depth with the depth this
number of wires is very close to what we
can show lower bounds for LTF circuits
and to the one plus something that
decays exponentially would be over by
result of cabinets in Lu there exists a
determinist we can extend this to
polynomial threshold functions circuits
with polynomial threshold gates for
example if all these polynomials are of
constant degree then we get a quasi
polynomial time algorithm that can
handle again n to the 1 plus something
that decays exponentially would be the
case faster but it doesn't matter right
now and the number of exceptional inputs
is slightly small it's due to the end to
the point 99 now why am I being so
obsessive about these exact parameters
here it's n to the 1 minus 2 to the
minus D and here n to the 1 plus 60 to
the minus T the reason is that the
following next theorem laid your chain
says that if we could get theorem 1 with
the same number of exceptional inputs
and even a slower algorithm but instead
of 60 we have another constant here
maybe 1 point 1 then we get the
randomization a lower bound for all of T
C 0
if there exists an algorithm for the
randomization of this is zero not
necessarily even linear threshold
circuits this number of wires and this
number of exceptional inputs and it
sufficiently quick say running in time
to to the end to the little o of one is
much larger than the essentially
polynomial time algorithm that we
actually have then we get our bounds for
of TC zero so the gap in this case
between what we know and what we need
for lower bounds lies in the exact base
of the exponent in the bound on the
number of wires
I'm going to rush through this through
aces you're with parity gates just
waving my hands for a bit we know the
depth for is hard in some sense it will
give standard randomization results and
in depth we we only know how to handle
certain structured cases so even the DEP
three case isn't finished yet
I want a survey there is other
techniques that underlie these result
results to get some kind of explanation
of what's going on here so the first
technique to get algorithmic results
follows the same high level strategies
that initially suggested by goda and
videos on this high level strategies as
follows given a circuit see with be
exceptional inputs we want to find a
simple function that approximates the
circuit in a large subset specifically
we want to find the function f over a
subset s such that s is large much
larger than be 10 times be 100 times B F
is close to C in this set and F is
sufficiently simple such that we can
approximate its bias inside this and we
can immediately see why this is helpful
the number of exceptional inputs B is
small the set s is very large so the
acceptance probability of C restricted
to s will be very biased towards the
majority output of C and since C
restricted to s is simple it's close to
a simple function we can approximate its
bias and learn how to majority output of
C's it should be reminiscent of stuff
that we know and we like to do
restriction methods as the switching
lemma so the one point here is that if
we want what we want to do is find
intuitively restrictions that simplify
the circuit not necessarily subject but
we need to find them algorithmically you
can't use random stuff so find the
underlying technical results for the
appearance that we saw are there under
musicians of restriction algorithms for
example add randomization of the
switching lemma that has very good
dependency on the width the CNF if the
width is W the seat length length is
approximately W squared log n which is
very good or so the random restriction
procedures with very short seedlings
that work for sparse LTF circuits and
PDF circuits
and I want to make a few comments first
this might might seem like this method
is ad-hoc but this method is actually
complete if we consult quantified the
randomization or the randomization in
any way we can solve it using this way
since what we originally were trying to
do is to find a constant function that
approximates the circuit in the entire
space now we want to find a simple
function that approximates it in a
subset the second comment which I've
mentioned that I want to stress the
subset s does not have to be a sub Q for
example I've mentioned results about AC
zero with parity gates obviously it's
not a sub cube there it's enough in
subspace so whenever I say restrictions
or stuff like that I mean just an
arbitrary set that we can somehow get a
handle and the third and crucial point
is that when we do these restriction
procedures we can and we do use white
box access to the circuit we look inside
the circuit and we tailor the set to
suit this specific circuit this is what
we do for a c0 with parity for LTF
circuits and for PDF circuits
any questions
so I'm moving on to the reduction of
standard randomization to quantify the
randomization and the high-level
approach is completely standard we're
going to do error reduction using
extractors or samples so we start from a
circuit see with 2 to the M over three
exceptional inputs and we construct a
circuit that takes its input uses an
extractor or sampler to sample inputs
for the original circuit C evaluates C
on the sample and takes a majority vote
if the sampler is good
the majority output of C prime will be
the majority output of C but the number
of exceptional inputs for C prime will
be tiny as good as the extractor allows
so what's the problem just plug in an
extractor and be done with it the
problem is that apparently explicit
extractors in weak computational models
haven't been studied this well before
and it's a very natural question the
rows after all that can trigger some
introduced it's practice problem so
indeed the technical results that
underlie the theorems that we saw are
explicit constructions of extractors and
we computational models I'm going to
hand with this a bit but randomly gave
and it's almost optimal extractor in AC
0 I to gather with the channel whether
an explicit extractor in TC 0 with an
extremely small number of wires and to
the 1 plus exponentially small ending
these attackers are used for error
reduction this is how we get the results
that we do standard randomization to
quantify them
so a few comments here first as I've
said these kind of questions were
surprisingly not studied before and the
second thing is an observation that
extractors here are Avast over killed we
don't really need them we use them only
because we kind of know how to construct
them already so extractors fool any test
information theoretically whereas we
want to fool a single test induced by a
small circuit whose description we have
so we could do with a much much weaker
object I'm going to get back to this
point in ten minutes or so
so now we come to an observation that
will explain what's going on with the
type results at least partially this
observation is that if we use these two
techniques a reduction and then
restrictions in a blackbox manner then
necessarily just combining them cannot
give standard randomization and give
very tight results but no more than that
I want to go slowly and be a bit more
specific so assume that we work in two
steps we get a circuit and in this first
step we do error reduction reduced error
from 2 to M over 3 to B Prime and we do
this by using the same extractor for
every circuit in the class we don't look
at the circuit that we were given and in
the second step we use restrictions for
quantified randomization so we have some
symbol so the random distribution that's
good for the entire class we sample from
it and we try to simplify this is the
circuit and this setter of size B our
hope would be that B would be larger
than B prime and as we get standard the
randomization as we reduce the problem
to B prime that is smaller than what we
can handle but unfortunately this can
never happen theorem says that if it's
the same extractor and one distribution
for the class necessarily B will be
smaller than B prime it's important but
it's not difficult to prove at all so
that will be even more specific for any
Class C that is reasonable if there is
an extractor in the class even an
extractor only for tests for so induced
by circuits in the class doesn't have to
be a full-fledged extractor that has
mean entropy such that the number of red
inputs is B Prime
and there is a distribution of size B
the necessarily B is smaller than B
prime intuitively the distribution would
simplify the extractor that's what's
going on here
so the meaning of this is that in order
to make progress in getting standard
randomization via this approach one of
the components must be white books you
cannot get around it although don't be
too discouraged white box does not mean
out of reach in this context
as I've mentioned actually most of the
results are already white books most of
the algorithmic results so for sparse
ic0 circuits with parity LTF circuits
and PDF circuits are techniques as is
are already white box unfortunately for
AC zero our techniques are fully black
box the reason that the nice is zero
things were so tight is that we simply
got a good randomization of acid
switching lemma a good extractor and
their tact another allows for questions
at this point
yeah so how you have results for AC zero
yeah and yet you said this this pair of
techniques there's this lemma right
anyway see you said you couldn't combine
those two steps so the thing is the
lemma says that take the best extractor
that you have it will bring you up to
this point and take the best
distribution that you have over
restrictions if we bring you up to some
point here it says that this point will
necessarily be to the left of that part
and this is what's going on here the
extractor is optimal has that switching
lemma is optimal after some logarithmic
factors that cannot be fully illuminated
by the lemon
fully explained what what's going on in
pc 0 this is the same with the number of
wires to begin with we want okay there
is an equivalence between extractors and
samples so if I have an extractor its
equivalent with min entropy log B Prime
it's equivalent to a sampler whose
number such that for any test the number
of bread inputs that over/under sampled
this test is like 2 to the min entropy
so it's B Prime yeah I interchangeably
used extractor and sampler but we're
using this as a sampler essentially
other questions
this is what I want to say about
circuits and like the highlight is that
the results are very tight that this
could be used as a platform further for
lower bounds further relaxation of
France methods and that if we want to
use this approach we have to do
something white box one wanna move on to
another setting we understand less well
this setting is the setting of hitting
polynomials that vanished fairly so
consider for the following standard
problem we fix a finite field F of size
Q and we consider the set of
multivariate polynomials f n2 f n is the
complexity parameter and the heating set
s is a set for a class P is a set such
that every polynomial in P evaluates to
non zero somewhere in the set we have
results for both our poor understanding
is equally poor in both settings it's
actually poorer for large fields so in
other words there's no polynomial in the
class that evaluates on all ofus and the
in the standard problem like we know of
non explicit sets it's just counting and
the problem is explicitly constructing a
hitting set generator so let's consider
the following problem start with the
class of degree D polynomials we know
that any hitting set for all the group D
polynomials has to be of at least of a
some size roughly n to the D this is an
easier so now I'm fixing a parameter B
which quantifies the number of zeros the
fraction of zeros of the polynomial
probability that problem polynomial
vanishes and I'm asking does there exist
the hitting set of smaller size if it
only needs to hit polynomials that
vanish on at most B of their inputs
note that this is interesting even not
explicitly even counting is not
straightforward some of these settings
just being a bit more specific fixed cue
the field size and fix D degree you can
be too if you want
let's short the values of B so if the
fraction of 0 is less than Q to the
minus D then there are no zeros this is
a classical result of Warnock so if B is
smaller than Q to the minus D this is
trivial
now denote by Delta the distance of
their corresponding reed-muller code so
beyond 1 minus Delta there is only the 0
polynomial there's nothing there we
cannot hit it the problem is interesting
in between between Q to the minus D and
1 minus Delta a random polynomial lies
here right it has like 1 over Q
approximately oh this is a classical
result at some point 1 is a monomial
so the game is inside here and note that
we will have like hard values in this
case will mean something different
hard values will mean value such that we
can lower abound in the size of a
heating set information theoretically
say that the heating set might must be
large and upper bounds might be either
explicit or non explicit and what we
know is radically different for GF 2 & 4
GF Q so for GF 2 we have upper bounds
what we don't have lower buttons the
upper bounds are both non-explicit one
can account and explicit that are worse
off almost exponentially from the non
explicit ones so for example if the if
BN is some parameters time 2 to the
minus D like take 10 to the minus D and
multiply it by D the non explicitly the
seed length is roughly log T times log M
and explicitly we can get this with an
additive overhead of T we try to put
some lower bounds in here I don't know
how to do it and it's in I mean 1 minus
10 times 2 to the minus D I'm sure that
the same lower bound holds it doesn't
help to do it well the other one think
now of keywords large Q is polynomial in
n in this setting we know of lower
bounds but we don't have any upper
bounds so I'm going to start with saying
that there are no non trivial upper
bounds at all even not explicitly I
don't know how to count and we have
lower bounds that are unconditional and
there are a bit ugly they are not good
so just as one application for example
if BN is Q to the minus 10 1 over Q to
the 10 or wine 1 over Q to the 100 then
the degree is super constant then there
is no polynomial size hitting set
generator it's just a sound byte if you
want t to be larger than the the lower
bounds get very ugly and my personal
feeling is that
well there are some results here we
don't really understand what's going on
I'm going to mention three or four open
problems but as I said before I think
that open problems here are essentially
everywhere since this is a broad
question that can be instantiated in
many settings so the first and most
prominent open problem is 40 c0 this is
a circuit lower bound frontier the
result that I mentioned says that if for
sufficiently small C and every depth D
you can into it you can intuitively find
restrictions for T C 0 of this size and
to the 1 plus C to the minus D then we
get lower bounds for all of this is 0
it's really the lower bounds that we do
have for C that is larger our via the
restriction method so there is no
inherent reason that if we change the
base of the exponent we are suddenly not
able to do this and as a first step
maybe a baby step can you find the set
even non explicitly not algorithmically
can you prove that there is some
structure and set that that this is zero
circuit simplify some other than it it's
set of ones and it's set of zeros this
might be a tractable problem and if it's
not it tells us a lot how come this tiny
change makes the problem completely
intractable
Oh for D equals two there are
restrictions by Ken Williams okay so
this starts being all parity equals yeah
but like if you want to get lower bounds
for this you need to go like to a large
D in order to get our bounds for smaller
D the question is you stated can be
asked for every fixed yeah definitely
right but then I wouldn't have said no
good point excellent so okay this is a
standalone problem it's very relevant
since this is a boolean devices workshop
and I want to mention a few problems
that seem more inherent or internal to
quantify the randomization the first one
as we know the algorithmic approach the
non-trivial algorithms that we need to
get the randomization might be non
deterministic in quantified
randomization this is really appealing
constructing non deterministic
algorithms for quantifying the
randomization for example in AC zero
it's very easy to make use of non
determinism you just get the restriction
the proof is the restriction you just
check it in general it's very intuitive
that if you want to simplify the circuit
then some kind of all-powerful God just
gives you the restriction and I really
just have to check it for sec oh I know
how to do it easy
and the second point which was what
something that was burning before in my
presentation I said that we need to do
something white box and I said that
extractors are an extreme overkill this
raises the question of white box
samplers and it's a very weird question
which is good because it might have not
been thought about too much so I'm not
allowed to use randomness right I'm a
deterministic algorithm but I'm going to
construct this other thing the sampler
which is allowed to use randomness and
it suited for that specific circuit and
it's to fool that specific circuit with
extremely high probability they have
some ideas on how to make progress with
this I think this is a promising thing
and the last one were actually two
frontiers that I want to mention first
hitting senators for polynomials when Q
is large
can you get any upper bound the fraction
of zeros is 2 times Q to the minus D
slightly non-trivial can we say anything
the the last point is that applying this
to other settings other than concept
that circuits and polynomials for
example Golda can be chosen in the
original paper thought about Merlin
Merlin Merlin Arthur and Arthur Merlin
what happens if they are right with
extremely high probability what can we
say everyone thank you very much
so with a leave time for questions you
mentioned non-deterministic the
randomization white box versus black box
and output melody so this one results
that I know with the paper with
Valentina Russell that if you have
non-deterministic white box the
organization of alpha meddling or in
fact of Merlin alpha then you have a
black box one so in some cases you don't
even if you use the circuit you know the
results I guess we never thought about
this restricted circuits where the phone
I mean maybe for other we just thought
about the program I guess it's
interesting for the models if you bus in
which case this can you eliminate can
you do that if you have white box
algorithm your black box of course the
most interesting one is just for
deterministically when I know for now
else I said
so what like I'm sampling properly you
need your lesson extractor to have just
needs to sample one test but about one
event the event is induced by a specific
circuit that you get needs to be correct
with extremely high probability like on
must be 2 to the N to the point 99
inputs in which this specific event is
not simple so it's not out of reach we
can do this with full fledged extractors
in these weak models but we want to gain
just a bit in the parameters right you
want to make the red in the green cross
there are already very close so if you
can utilize the white box properties in
some way which I have some ideas on how
to do it and again just a little bit in
the parameters maybe you can wait
okay well let's think growing
[Applause]